tests yep all right looks good yeah
should I do it
go for it I'll do it
cause you had a bad day you're taking
one day you turn into a bug just to turn
it around
[Music]
no way dude no wait that was so good I'm
afraid of getting a copyright strike
plastic pills pod cast pill pod 94
this is fiction neither philosophy nor
critical theory but
we're almost getting close to the big
three dige
yeah
it might be theory that lurks its way in
here we'll see
specifically the text by Kafka
this is this is the text that all of us
Force our students to read when they
fail to turn in an assignment and they
blame it on mental health issues right
guys I think we just like to torture
students with this because it's uh
relatively short and disturbing it's a
very it's a very effective policy
no I'm kidding because that would be
cruel and probably illegal actually but
I found this reading again immensely
enjoyable
um even humorous at the same time as
being
incredibly Bleak so trigger warning
content warning
epilepsy warning in case you need one of
those and of course spoiler warning
because we are gonna spoil the end of
the book uh not a book short story short
story yeah so I've written in 19 uh
before 1920 ish
but you've had your chance to finish it
is what I'm saying so listener here's
your chance to pause it because the
ending spoiler comes in five four three
and not just the ending to metamorphosis
but also to
the trial the Hunger Artist the penal
colony
the protagonist dies at the end and
everyone else is happier for it is that
what happens in everything they all die
and then people are better off at least
those four those are those are the four
endings I recall am I missing any there
are no happy endings for Kafka usually
but uh yeah this one we are talking of
course about the metamorphosis this one
is an infamously Bleak take on things
yeah so we we were just banging around
ideas about where to go with this and uh
I read a noblekov quote that said or
quotation excuse me
we are within English
uh PhD ABD here so I should get my quote
versus quotation correct it won't be a
second time yeah
Nabokov quotation saying that Kafka is
the greatest writer German writer of our
time such poets as a real K or novelists
like Thomas man mon are dwarves or
plaster Saints in comparison to him
and as he kind of insert he introduced
himself already but with us today
it's Eric and I and no lib Vic today
because he's traveling but filling in is
litvik not to be confused but currently
ABD PhD in English literature so if
you're a regular listener you probably
know him from past episodes
and Vic do you remember when you were
last on what episode it was yeah I think
we did the purloin letter from Edgar out
oh right right
which is actually this one's a good
follow-up to that because we're kind of
back in that territory of kind of uh you
know people having a bad day in the
bureaucratic State let's put it that way
that is very true he does complain a lot
about his job in a very different way
than uh than old Bartleby does
but we're finally executing our literary
follow-up to those episodes and Kafka
himself I believe worked in insurance so
maybe all the whining books whining
through literature is is permitted here
yeah yeah samsa is a traveling salesman
Gregor samsa and uh kafka's got some
good uh words some technical words to
describe the bureaucratic structure of
his job so it implies some kind of
insight unless this is just stuff people
from the early 20th century would know
about but I have a feeling he's got some
insight into this kind of garbage job
work yeah just before we get into this
story specifically uh Victor you're
teaching this as you mentioned or you
have taught it right yeah it's it's been
on the syllabus once or twice yeah yeah
okay so I wanted to ask you because
I've read Kafka several times several
classes throughout all the years
and the words that come up are like
Dread and the crushing bureaucracy and
claustrophobia in terms of either the
style or the content uh variously but
the thing that I hear almost all the
time and I wanna I Wanna Get rid of it
because I think if it's set all the time
there's something sloganized and perhaps
misleading about it but Kafka expresses
the alienation of modernity
which sounds
a little vague I don't like the term
modernity so much so I'd wondered if you
could just uh respond or react to that
that that phrasing and maybe enrich it a
little bit for us sure I mean it does
start with some truth I mean Kafka was
writing in the early Decades of the 20th
century in Central Europe and this was
kind of where we get the the early
beginnings of what kind of becomes like
recognizably again like the bureaucratic
administrative state that has only
become more relatable over time so when
we're talking about things like the nine
to five office job you know this this
sense of the the bureaucratic State
um we do start to see this developing
more and more in the larger cities of
Europe in the early 20th century and
that's why like it's easy to kind of
think of things as as of Kafka perhaps
as kind of articulating these anxieties
from that time
but it for this story specifically yeah
I I think we have to kind of definitely
go a little bit beyond that and not just
look at Greg or samhsa's famous
transformation into a giant insect
spoiler alert as some sort of metaphor
for capitalism or for the sort of
bureaucratic state which it certainly is
on one level perhaps but also to take
this transformation at face value and
actually kind of perhaps think about it
literally a little bit and consider like
if we take Kafka at his word like what
are we to make here of this individual
who wakes up one day and is completely
disembodied from his form he has to sort
of be reborn into the world in a certain
sense and the relationship that he now
has with his family which is completely
altered and all of the interesting
interpretive possibilities that that
opens up so leaving aside for a minute
perhaps you know Gregor's relation to
like his work or anything like that or
the questions of alienation there
there's a lot of other interesting
directions you can take this story
because what makes it so ripe and so
kind of like continually relevant is
that it doesn't really it's very minimal
in terms of the commentary like Kafka
does not give us a simple answer are
here for like what's going on what are
we to make of this really strange
bewildering story like we have to kind
of finish it ourselves we have to
interpret it ourselves so it's one of
those stories it's it's it's very modern
in that sense that like there's no easy
kind of like moral attached to it we
have to kind of like make it relevant
for our own time and that's one of the
really fun things about this story I
think is that like it it is surprisingly
versatile that way like there are so
many ways we can kind of unpack like
what happens here and
Beyond just the typical starting point
of you know kind of like questions of
marxist alienation or perhaps even
objection there's there's a lot of
critical stuff that can be kind of
thrown at this story but even that kind
of is just a starting point I think for
uh unpacking uh kafka's World here yeah
so it's a good uh way to describe it uh
alienation modernity well if you want to
sound smart at a dinner party but we
gotta go beyond it and and kafka's
writing is is so significant that he
also has a entire uh adjective after him
named after him right yes right
nightmarish complexity bizarre illogical
like uh the trappings of bureaucracy
being crushed under the weight of a kind
of
being really low down on the ladder of a
giant bureaucracy where you can't really
see the top and you just feel like
you're subject to arbitrary and
illogical kinds of forces it's one of
those terms that I think like everyone
is Loosely familiar with but which can
actually be quite hard to Define yeah so
the the kafka-esque is basically like
like you said Eric like this dealing
with this like nightmarish bureaucratic
world where which what's interesting we
we start with a very grounded realistic
kind of like world but then things
quickly spiral out of control and we
then start to just kind of have this
like weird sluggish illogical sense of
things where nothing is really
accomplished and the character is just
kind of like lost in a maze so it's
quite relatable even in the modern world
in that sense yeah a hard time that's
certainly true although in this text at
least the bureaucracy is mentioned but
it's kind of external and it's kind of
at a distance whereas the only you know
the only Kafka novel that is properly
cough gask is the trial I'd think no
yeah that's where I could see the
alienation description being really
relevant because it's also very
impersonal there's no there's there
seems to be no face on the bureaucracy
it's just this sort of
structure this thing we're kind of
caught in the middle of it we can't see
the top and it just feels arbitrary and
but emphasis also on just bizarre and
nightmarish too it's just it's just wild
you have to just kind of accept you know
the first line transformed into an
enormous bug for instance here
it's just something you just have to
accept and deal with throughout and it's
a little bit painful in a way to read
through it but yeah when we're
describing something as kafka-esque it's
just very strange weird frightening it's
interesting that you bring up all those
words because I thought this was
humorous
and same with the trial like all these
things are react are happening to him
the reactions are very funny but before
we get to pulling the pieces of this
apart a little bit I thought I'd just
give a summary in case anyone's here
doing their their English Lit homework
because the plot you could summarize in
a few sentences the dude I'll just read
the first sentence because it's really
significant very often quoted
um one morning when Gregor samsa woke
from Troubled Dreams he found himself
transformed in his bed into a horrible
vermin and some some translations say
Buck I guess he laid on his armor-like
back and if he lifted his head a little
he could see his brown belly slightly
domed and divided by arches into stiff
sections the bedding was hardly able to
cover it and seemed ready to slide off
at any moment his many legs pitifully
thin compared to the size of the rest of
him waved about helplessly as he looked
and then the entire plot takes place in
one apartment in the family unit but the
family unit as you guys were kind of
alluding to it keeps getting disrupted
by people from the outside people from
his job come in
renters come in
the the cleaning lady comes in and they
all have a different sort of interaction
with Gregor the now insect and the type
of or not insect I should say bug or
Vermin it's not even said what kind of
bug he is
I mean pills's reaction is interesting I
mean I'm not I'm not sure well I guess
because it's not a clear you know
allegory metaphor we want to stay away
from that sort of thing I guess it
really does depend on your sense of
humor and if you're at home in
kinds of
categories of pessimism and nihilism and
those sorts then then this is really
you're locked in your house during covid
yeah oh yeah I mean that's perfect that
really captures the kind of cloistered
nature of this whole thing right it
feels very much like you could go back
and read some Gothic literature like
like what's that one the monk or even
something old like castle of a tranto
and it's very cloistered it's very
interiority but in the interiority of
rooms and houses and you just feel very
hemmed in
and if you respond to that sort of thing
in a humorous way that's that's your
interpretation in a certain way I'm not
sure if if kafka's necessarily going
there with it but I mean one of his uh
the the executor of his State
um I forget his name
but he described a conversation uh Max
broad is the executor of his State he
describes a conversation going uh with
Kafka
um where Kafka says we are nihilistic
thoughts Suicidal Thoughts that come
into God's head
oh Kafka says our world is only a bad
mood of God a bad day of his so actually
that opening uh that opening riff isn't
such a bad description actually it's a
yeah God had a bad day and then he
thought of us
well if I can elaborate on why I find
this funny a little bit because I I
think it'll give give way to some
meaning is the absurdity of it because
he wakes up he says what's happened to
me and immediately his next thought is
how am I gonna get dressed and get to
work when I have bug legs like how am I
gonna make the Train on time I can't be
sick today so there's no question of oh
what is this what's happened to me it's
immediately I'm a bug but how am I gonna
get to work
no and that that's definitely where the
comic tone comes from because like
Gregor isn't really even bothered by his
transformation at first yeah it's more
the fact that he's gonna be late for
work that he has trouble getting out of
bed and things escalate in a pretty
funny way because then he's worried well
what if my boss comes looking for me at
home I'm already five minutes late and
then sure enough you know you hear the
boss knocking at his bedroom door
somehow he's already there the boss is
arguing with his parents so it really
escalates in this like nightmarish way
but there's definitely kind of like a
comic takeaway that you could have from
all of this like Gregor seems to be more
than anything else worried about losing
his job so the whole transformation into
a bug thing is is almost like secondary
to his uh his financial obligations at
that point and the Very I know we well
okay we should explain why we're gonna
not do an allegorical reading but as
soon as I read this part I'm like oh
it's about depression he doesn't want to
go to work but it has to has to get out
of bed and then his family is
increasingly tired of him like sitting
around in his room I was like okay this
is about depression but reading um both
Nabokov and de Liz and gutari who I
think are quoting nabukov without saying
his name there's they say you cannot
read this as an allegory it's not a
metaphor and since we have our purse
expert and what a metaphor is as a sign
and all that here I wanted to ask you
Eric what you thought about reading this
as a metaphor or an allegory or
something that means like a one-to-one
comparison a sign into signifier yeah
well I I wouldn't I wouldn't fix a
meaning to it right like it's not a it's
breaking conventions whereas in person
symbols are conventional meanings on the
other hand metaphors are more
allegorical right they they set up a
likeness between two things like an
allegory is an extended metaphor for
example right it's an extended before
which you describe in detail and
everything involved in it is meant to
you know mean something else to provide
some kind of comparison you know for the
literary folk write a comparison without
using like or as
but what is a metaphor for depression
okay maybe is it a metaphor for like the
weight of capitalism right this is the
early days of capitalism you got to
think there's World War One ramping up
going into it in the background of this
as well there's there's all kinds of you
know you know Marx had written about the
Jewish question and that question was
still very much alive at this time
even before World War II
um
and in a sense you can't pin it down to
any of those meanings because this is so
domestic in a certain way there's no
there's no there's no proof in the text
there's no evidence in the text you
could really drop on to nail it down as
a metaphor for this or that thing
in a comparative sense it doesn't form I
mean purse would call it a likeness what
is this like it's it kind of is what it
is in a certain way and we have to do
the work yeah and just to add on to that
what's what's really fascinating here is
that you don't even have to look for a
metaphor because the metaphor has
already become literal right it's not
that Gregor is like a bug or that he is
bug-like he literally is a bug so that
in itself kind of like slaps you in the
face and like presents you with the
physical like literal nature of this
transformation right so in the way and
especially the fact that Kafka doesn't
actually describe him in detail but he
just kind of leaves a little bit
ambiguous but clearly there's been a
physical transformation he already is
kind of steering us maybe towards
looking at this in in more grounded
terms which is kind of what makes this
again so weird and unsettling even to
read because that there's this weight
there's this physicality to this world
that Kafka is describing even though it
has like all all the appearance of a
nightmare you really feel like you're
there with Gregor kind of like figuring
things out for the for the first time in
this new state yeah and metaphors tend
to take you somewhere else especially
allegories especially religious
allegories they tend to point somewhere
else they point to some Transcendent
other place right but you know kafka's
favorite line oh there's plenty of hope
there's an infinite amount of Hope but
not for us right we're that we're that
those bad thoughts in the head of God
right we can't escape
so metaphor Is No Escape for us allegory
Is No Escape there's no Transcendence
within this imminence it's just we just
have this this [ __ ] show that Kafka
describes for us
so I mean that's that's also coming from
your reading of Nabokov right he's
saying this this is not the closest
thing we get to a metaphor and this
whole story is probably the Apple which
we'll get to a bit later
but everything else really just is a
head scratcher
it's it's really weird and we sh we
should also point out as well that so
Nabokov was like notoriously kind of
adamant about people not allegorizing
his own work and he was especially kind
of like uh critical of Freud and
psychoanalysis so we we can't completely
say that Nabokov speaks for Kafka here
because we don't know the extent to
which Kafka himself might have wanted to
like bring up certain associations or
implications with this kind of magical
transformation that Gregor goes through
but yeah so I think Nabokov is certainly
on to something here insofar as he's
kind of like
urging us to take this story at face
value first and foremost and then we can
kind of dress it up a little bit further
and kind of you know bring in other
readings or traditions in play yeah
all right so the big the setup we know a
little bit about Gregor's backstory and
we find out that in a sense before the
story started like yesterday presumably
he was uh he was in a human body now
he's in a bug body but even the day
before he turns into this bug
and he's worried about getting to work
we find out he's kind of Trapped in his
family structure by his job because his
dad is bankrupt and he's sort of the
breadwinner for the family it sounds
like so he has to go to work because his
dad is unable to work
um and that's why he's a little bit
frantic immediately about you know
getting to his job he has to get the
right train and the first plot point
that happens they're all trying to get
him out of bed
he can't get out of bed because he's got
six legs they're all trying to get him
out of bed but they haven't seen him yet
and even not having seen him his his uh
they call it a clerk which I guess is
like something like an office manager
there's some time period stuff in there
maybe you guys know about but his clerk
comes to his house because he has missed
the train it's right there imagine
you're like manager or your boss just
like coming to your house
that's that's already pretty scary
that's already a kind of invasion I
don't know if they'd regard it the same
way at this time but that is very much
you know you can't you're trapped in
this house and yet your boss is there
with your family like being like hey oh
my God and some of the [ __ ] he says to
Greg R2 is just insane I would quit my
job but obviously he can't there's a lot
of reasons why he cannot
oh yeah I'm excited to get into it I
don't want to run too far ahead with
that though
and he seems to be very worried about
the hierarchy at work
where If he if he doesn't arrive on time
he's going to get written up by the
office like we get it we get a look into
the hierarchy of his work where there's
a whole bunch of terms that I have no
familiarity with but it's like the head
clerk the office assistant but you can
kind of imagine that this probably
crashed really well into a modern office
with here he got the HR we got the
supervisor we got the boss and uh all
that kind of weird structure that is
never fully explained maybe the time
period like a contemporary reader would
get these terms a little more it was I
don't know what they all mean though and
it's it's worth noting too that Gregor
seems to have had some sort of military
background so I don't know how much that
kind of influenced how he sees his
workplace but it does seem to be very
regimented very hierarchical like he is
that kind of hog in the machine but
what's also interesting about his family
status or his home life is like even
though it seems like like he's just
living at home with his parents it's
like actually they're living with him
like he bought this apartment he's kind
of like subsidizing their incomes and
that's why they depend on him so much to
kind of get to work and everything so
it's interesting in that sense because
they they don't seem to be very
supportive or sympathetic once he kind
of runs into these physical difficulties
like they just seem to kind of view this
as a financial problem for them at that
point it's like oh no our our son can't
work therefore he is now a problem like
there's very it seems very transactional
at that point
and the bankrupt's father goes back to
work after he turns into a bug
so presumably there's no reason that he
couldn't be working they're just living
off him and then as soon as he turns
into a bug then they got to go back to
work the sister becomes a sales girl
yeah they all have to kind of like make
do without him in a way and they manage
but they seem very annoyed that they
have to work yeah without Gregor and
it's interesting that you bring up the
uniform because the uniform comes up a
few times everyone who comes in or not
everyone some of the people that come
into the house they're wearing uniforms
his father sleeps in his uniform there's
a picture of Gregor on the wall with his
military uniform so you I I think that's
not a a reach to understand what Kafka
is trying to do there describing first
of all these work hierarchies these and
then these uh other forms of hierarchy
or something yeah one thing one thing
that is actually funny is that at first
he tries to rationalize this extremely
absurd situation where he's transformed
into a giant bug saying my God what a
strenuous job I've chosen it's like work
stress has turned him in like he's just
rationalizing it he's like oh man maybe
if I just go back to sleep he's he's
thinking about how hard his job is like
oh I have to travel all the time and I
don't I'm not able to have like
relationships that go beyond like
perfunctory formal courtesy uh he's he's
just rationalizing it and you're just
reading it thinking like how is he
actually thinking of this as an
explanation for his situation but it it
also makes sense because he's just kind
of ignoring it because he's he's got
this one track mind he's like gotta
support the family got to support the
family but father had a business
collapsed about five years ago it's got
a little bit saved up but not a whole
lot so they're just completely living
off of his paychecks and he says I'm
happy to give it to them I'm happy to do
this but it's very stressful maybe
that's why I'm I'm a giant bug
yeah and he really seems to have like no
sense of self Beyond his job like his
hobby is like studying train timetables
he's like it's pretty much his whole
life but it's it's it's interesting
because you mentioned Eric like yeah he
he can form relationships with people
and that's almost like even even his job
as of traveling salesman kind of like
touches on that right like he's always
on the move he doesn't really have like
a fixed State outside of his work so
yeah there there's a lot that goes into
kind of you know this this the sense of
him being just identified with his job
the point where like he has no
relationship with his family even
outside of you know Gregor Samson it's a
completely grotesque and inexplicable
reversal of dependency because suddenly
he depends on them to slide food under
the table he he depends on the sort of
sympathy of his sister to figure out
what foods he likes now and figure out
how he wants his room arranged like does
he want the furniture up against the
wall or should the furniture be pulled
away from the wall and he's kind of
listening in on what they're saying but
he's completely depends on them now even
though for
presumably about five years they've been
completely dependent on him
and then it's just an inexplicable
reversal of that and it generates a
Little Bit of Sympathy for Gregor right
off the bat for that I think
but then you understand it's like but
how can you live with this bug in the
house
yes this sounds it sounds a little bit
like it could be
autobiographical I don't know because I
didn't want to psychologize the reading
because I think those are often the most
superficial readings but the the the
structure I guess you could call it the
edible structure just being penetrated
all the time by these bureaucratic
structures from outside we get a real
sense of
there's no boundary of the house from
external
excuse me bureaucracy and internal
bureaucracy
and I just wanted to read a a quotation
that illustrates this so his but he
misses his train and his boss or chief
cleric whatever that is comes in to his
house
and he says
Mr samsa what is wrong you barricade
yourself in your room give us no more
than yes or no for an answer you are
causing serious and then unnecessary
concern to your parents and you fail and
I mentioned this just by the way you
fail to carry out your business duties
in a way that is quite unheard of I am
speaking here on behalf of your parents
and of your employer and really must
request a clear and immediate
explanation I am astonished quite
astonished I thought I knew you as a
common sensible person and now you
suddenly seem to be showing off with
peculiar whims so he gets turned into a
bug and his boss comes to his house to
guilt him on behalf of his parents whom
he is supporting
yeah pretty presumptuous on the part of
his well I just call it a manager or
something head manager comes to the
house I'm speaking on behalf of the boss
and your family oh okay pretty
presumptuous there and then no sense of
gratitude which I think is something we
can all you know identify with you know
you've been giving your life to this
company running yourself into the ground
and then as soon as you do one thing
wrong it's like suddenly the guy implies
that he's stealing you know oh maybe
it's that the boss gave you these uh
cash checks the other day and now
suddenly you're not coming to work hmm
it's like whoa dude back the [ __ ] off
man like is there no gratitude for the
life that has been given to you no
that's just how it works in kafka's
world
idea what the job situation what like
what a chief clerk is and I've already
said this but this cannot be normal even
in Prague in the early 1900s so there's
definitely something going on here
uh referencing this inner penetration of
your work life and home life and how
it's bleeding into the same thing
yeah we we know that Kafka himself
didn't have like a great relationship
with his father and he actually referred
to like the family unit in some of his
letters as like an organism so he he
might be drawing a little bit from his
own experience here in terms of some of
the anxieties or resentments even but
even without getting all like
autobiographical on it yeah like there
there there's this enormous like tension
and anxiety that clearly is all kind of
like building up here where everyone is
outside his door everyone expects
something of him and it's like in a way
Gregor is just like starting from
scratch here he's figuring out his own
body he's just like almost been reborn
in a certain way he has he's really
incapable of delivering what they need
from him and what's interesting is the
the quote that you mentioned pills where
um the manager is outside his door
berating him that's before they've
actually seen him in his new form
because that's when like things really
take a turn for the grotesque as as Eric
mentioned like we we it's it's hard to
like on understate how like disgusting
Gregor is in this story you know like he
can't actually talk to them he's hissing
all the time he leaves this like slimy
Trail wherever he tries to move around
he's crawling up the walls later on so
like even as readers we're kind of like
I don't know it's a little bit
disgusting to be like in the same room
as this character for that long like
it's really off-putting in a certain way
so that's something that he stinks right
his sister has to like open the window
and breathe at the window every now and
then because it presumably just smells
like crap in there
and this grotesqueness of his body now
his his legs that seem to sort of have a
mind of their own at first I don't know
if this is a mark of kafka's style but
these really minute descriptions like he
really drags you through the details
and immediately after that part you know
he his boss is outside his manager I
should say is outside and he does try to
open the door and kafka's sort of
details he offers to that are amazing
the way he props himself up the way he
sort of slides along the wall and then
he puts his mouth on the key and this
sort of really heart-rending part where
he's like oh what they should be saying
is go on Gregory you can do it get the
door open they have no idea what he's
going through on the other side of that
door and he describes his mouth being on
the key and this like brown liquid then
he's like hurting himself doing this
chomping down on this key cutting his
mouth and this brown liquid is pouring
out of his mouth as he's trying to open
this door
he's trying to explain himself at the
same time and presumably he just sounds
like
and that is manager turns to the family
yes did you get a [ __ ] word of that
what did he just say he's offering this
very rational explanation and it's all
just so obscene it's it makes you it
makes your skin crawl a little bit just
reading those those scenes especially
yeah it's almost like in some ways calf
because like daring us as readers to be
like disgusted in the way that the
family is it's like all right what how
much further can I go before you like
feel that feel what the parents are
feeling basically because that I think
yeah that's actually where a lot of the
narrative tension here comes from
because like there's a lot of sympathy
that we would want to have towards
Gregor but like he is a man-sized insect
you know like at a fundamental level
like it is off putting here the
characters associated with something
which is just like gross so right away
we we ourselves have to work to have any
sense of like human empathy for this
individual such a contrast with what you
might read at this time too I can't
imagine you know reading this versus
reading you know what would you be
reading at this time like The Great
Gatsby by Fitzgerald or The Sun Also
Rises which are are very sort of prim
and proper and Polished and elegant and
they don't take you into this grotesque
world of disgusting juices and slimes
and buggy legs
streams of like oh so sad for Gregor but
he's so disgusting the same time how am
I supposed to feel yeah just
just to mention the closest precedent
for that would be something like
probably dostoevsky's underground man
like you know somebody who's clearly
like isolated and like aloof but like
not disgusting to this level yeah like
but someone clearly undergoing some sort
of like existentialist trial yeah
or in terms of the bureaucracy
mechanisms that you're trapped in the
one we read Bartleby
period except there's no like that's a a
description from outside and what I was
thinking this this is the short story
takes what two hours maybe three hours
to read just
the plot you could summarize in three
paragraphs and finish it easily the plot
doesn't really matter so much as what
Eric was talking about these minute and
intense descriptions not only of the
world and like how he's trying to get
his pants on how he's trying to open the
door but also his feelings his feelings
of of like
I don't I guess he doesn't really feel
revolted by himself he kind of
understands why his family is treating
him this way but his expectations from
his family but compared to their
responses to him he looks around hoping
to see this but instead he sees them
doing this and he doesn't really
identify
I mean he he kind of shows some
understanding of why they would be
treating a man-sized insect like this
but he doesn't really that's not part of
his shock I guess you could say none of
his shot comes from being a bug it comes
from the way they treat him for being a
bug Gregor is actually quite curious
about his new situation like he's kind
of exploring his legs checking things
out and it's it's more so like his
family who are like completely disgusted
by what he has become like they're yeah
there it does kind of pose the question
of like you know
if his family was was able to
accommodate him in a certain way would
would this necessarily be a tragedy
because yeah like spoiler alert again
the story ends in Gregor's gradual death
because like he's abused by his family
they don't know how to take care of him
properly and eventually he just like
feebly crawls off and dies so
that's it's the families actually
relieved at that point and it it kind of
again
suggests that maybe if they had just
sort of uh
interpreted the situation differently
Gregor didn't have to be like cast out
in this way because Gregor as a bug is
not like terrified of himself it's more
so that everyone else around him doesn't
know what to do with him anymore at that
point
how do you read that
if you want to well he doesn't fit into
conventional social Frameworks anymore
right like physically and socially
there's something about him which can no
longer be classified and that's where
like this opens up in so many
interesting interpretive ways because
like is is Gregor like disabled in a
certain sense is there something queer
about him is there something like Beyond
just the sort of marxist financial
implications here
there's there's clearly ways in which
like the family fail as caregivers
towards Gregor's new state right except
maybe the sister because the sister does
seem to at least try to like
you know bring him rotten vegetables and
stuff and kind of like
try to see Gregor as a bug but everyone
else is just like not having it
which by the way she's not abusing him
he he only wants to eat rotten
vegetables no no she speaks in milk
which he's like what must be his
favorite drink
she arranges the room for him so he can
crawl more freely so actually the
ultimate betrayal is her because she's
like we would be better off if we just
forgot that he was our brother and let
him die
whereas she's the only one who shows any
amount of uh empathy for him at the at
the first couple days or the first we
don't know how long the story goes on
exactly but at the beginning she is the
only one who still sees him as Gregor or
tries to and the real tragedy is
eventually in a way right she kind of
drops this reasonable thought saying you
know if if he really was my brother if
he really was our our Gregor he wouldn't
put us through this for so long right
and Gregor's getting a little bit pissed
as The Story Goes On because they're
sort of losing their you know they're
losing their will to do what they're
doing you know she figures out he likes
old cheese so she comes in and looks at
what he does and doesn't eat tries to
bring him more of the stuff he does eat
and but eventually just becomes too much
of a burden and for him it's like well
yeah he supported them for so long but
that on the other hand you know Kafka
holds out this kind of very perverse
hope he tortures you with this hope that
maybe he'll change back maybe maybe it's
just a cold but you eventually realize
he's not going back to the way he was
it's not a phase Mom this is who I am
yeah it's it's it's really hard to kind
of tell how comically we should be
taking it but there's a deep tragedy of
course by the end where like they just
they refuse to accept that this is their
son or their brother anymore it's like
we just want to move on and like Gregor
has gone to us even as like Greg or the
bug like meekly is like looking around
the corner and hissing at them so
depending on the different literary
approaches you want to take here it
opens itself up to every reading because
you were normal you were part of the
family unit even the base of the family
unit then something about you changes
and now you are
we we kind of try to accommodate you for
a little while but eventually you just
become a complete annoyance and everyone
wishes you would go back to the way you
were or just die
so I know our listeners you could put in
whatever fill in the blank into whatever
you know relatable analogy you have he
doesn't give any clues as to what that
analogy is except maybe the Apple thing
which maybe we should bring up but yeah
it's a story of someone who fit no
longer fits spatially leave her down
middle but in another sense he's now on
the outside he's outside the Family
Circle but spatially he's in a room in
the middle of the house there's Doors
and Rooms a budding on his room on
either side and he kind of is flitting
around inside this little cave that
becomes real nasty and smelly
and it's a it's a very cloistered Gothic
feeling where he's stuck in there and he
becomes this sort of it becomes almost
like um so that that that Russian Film
the um uh where the guy leads them into
that sort of um dead zone that that
no-go Zone where yeah yeah his room
almost becomes that that area that zone
where you go in and everything's just
sort of not the way things should be
everything's uncanny and a little bit
strange
but
yeah it's pretty much they want to just
like condemn his bedroom and just like
forget that he's there they actually
have like uh these uh renters who come
in towards the end and they're actually
quite pleased with some of the apartment
they're interested and then they see
Gregor and they're like nah nah nah we
we change our mind we don't want to live
here anymore and the family's like God
damn it Gregor just [ __ ] off we're
trying to sell the house yeah so it's it
just becomes again it's constantly a
financial problem the perverse sense is
his transformation brings life back to
his father too right because his father
starts to be assertive he's assertive
with those those renters he's also much
more assertive towards towards Gregor he
pokes him with the broom he he kind of
Corrals them around with weapons and
then he eventually bombards him with
apples when they have this confrontation
and this weird little dance as he can't
turn very well so he kind of charges at
him in the father's side steps and then
he's slow Gregor slowly turns and then
charges at him and they have this weird
little dance and then the father just
ends up sort of
putting apples in his pockets because
now he's like dressing up and going out
and he has this regular these regular
clothes on now before he's just kind of
sitting around in bathrobes and sleeping
at the table and and having breakfast
for like four hours a day
and then his father is kind of Life
comes back to his father again and you
get this sense oh my God was this like
the family became dependent on him to
the point where they were becoming
slovenly and they were not thriving even
though in Gregor's mind like it was all
him carrying them along surfacing their
debts making sure that nobody comes
collecting
and then in the end you know actually
his removal kind of breathed new life
into them they all got jobs they all
came into their own and really you could
look at this as almost like a
coming-of-age story for his sister as
well by the end of the story she blooms
like literally she turns into a young
woman she stretches out like the story
ends on that note with her not with
Gregor's death but with the family
finally all leaving the house and the
sister you know stretching and they
realize she's a young woman now and so
there's that hope
but then as soon as the Hope emerges the
story ends
he's replaced he's successfully so yeah
there's a happy ending at least for his
sister yeah in that sense
so there's two uh little artifacts in
this story and maybe more if you think
of them but two that I was puzzled by
and I wanted to ask you guys about uh
the two are the Apple
and the picture of the woman
and why don't we start with the Apple
because I think that'll probably take a
little bit longer yeah I set that up a
little bit but that's the thing I said
maybe that's the metaphor but what could
it be the metaphor of you know you have
the
the Apple supposedly that was eaten from
the Tree of knowledge of Good and Evil
I don't know if there's no textual
evidence to support that interpretation
a kind of forbidden fruit
so while pla in the plot what happens I
should explain this and the plot what
happens he's trying to get back to his
or he's trying to turn around to go back
to his room because he find out finds
out he's not wanted and his dad starts
throwing apples at him and if you
imagine he's probably got some sort of
carapass or like armor on his back and
the Apple gets stuck in the armor and it
and starts like sitting there and
rotting and I think it eventually it
causes him pain for a long time and
might be part of why he died but anyway
the Apple an apple is willing to go in
and take it out because they write they
they make no effort to establish
communication with them they're very
minimal communication going on there
even though Gregor is all there he's all
he's he's rational he's thinking but
there's this just wall between him and
his family literally and metaphorically
there's a wall between them yeah so
there's a few things to note there
around that because that symbol does
sort of jump out especially in a story
which is this sparse about like
furniture and things like that yeah so
one thing to note is first of all
Gregor's family is actually seen to be
Christians they're Catholics right like
they cross themselves a few times so
even though Kafka himself is from a
Jewish Family there there's clearly kind
of like a religious Dimension here which
we probably shouldn't ignore and the
connection of the apple with original
sin of course is as you noted Eric is is
the most obvious one that comes up but
then the question comes back to like why
did this happen to Gregor in the first
place right like is he being punished
for something like normally at least in
like traditional classical sorts of
metamorphosis when somebody gets turned
into an animal or an an odd like a plant
whatever it's because they've done
something you know they've they've
displeased the gods or they have sinned
in a certain way and they are now being
punished for that right and that
tradition would definitely have been
like would not have been far from the
minds of kafka's readers and even Kafka
himself so on one level we are perhaps
being invited to think about like why is
Gregor suffering here you know what has
he done and is there a reason why you
know his father is pelting apples at him
with all of the kind of edible and
judeo-christian implications that that
has right and
what we're really left with is like it's
no aside from like being a provider for
his family we don't really know anything
else about this guy like it's not clear
why he has been punished if indeed this
is a punishment right and so I don't
know we we kind of seem to just be left
with this almost nihilistic sense of
like
there's there isn't this sense of
justice in this universe at least where
you know this man is being punished for
a reason it's just bad things are
happening to good people and it's not
clear why right and if that's a
commentary on the modern world more
broadly or if it's like a religious
statement like that's for us to decide
but it it does raise some interesting
theological implications I think yeah
the fact that
in you know in say of its Metamorphoses
right that's it that's it when you're a
Immortal and you you spy a God say you
know there's a story where someone comes
up and sees a god getting changed and
they're naked in the woods and then you
know you get turned into something as
punishment you metamorphosize into some
non-human creature as punishment and at
least to the reader that it's clear you
know it's a little bit arbitrary you
know and that the gods they don't punish
you for just reasons they simply punish
you for transgressing but here there's
boundaries everywhere and it's not sure
it's not clear which boundary which
transgression you've crossed you've
committed that's incurred this
punishment and so what what has he done
you know God is completely sort of left
unmentioned except for those those
little hints at it you pointed towards
so has he done something wrong is it
because
this this good thing he thinks he's been
doing for his family has actually been
holding them back he claims that he's
been staying in this job and they've
been holding him back but in a sense his
care for them has been holding them back
and so there is that the sort of
arbitrary Whimsical punishment that he's
suffering it's it's not clear right and
the and the Apple
maybe suggests that sort of thing a kind
of a kind of throwback to a a weird
paganistic kind of transgressive
attitude that is completely out of place
and because God is supposed to punish
you for moral transgressions right
because he's morally perfect the old
gods are not morally perfect they're not
exemplars to be followed
there's a lot there and it's yeah it is
those are interesting questions to ask I
was just wondering before we get to the
portrait is it significant that the
father
delivers this punishment after oh yeah
yeah
um after after he's been such a good son
he's been like taking care of the family
he's been doing his duty the second he
stops doing his duty because he got
turned into a bug then he gets punished
by the father and is this is not edible
I swear to God I was thinking biblically
it is it's very it's very biblical I
don't think it's an accident at all that
the Father Figure here is pelting apples
at the sun I mean it's it's dripping
with symbolism because aside from like
the actual sort of biblical tradition
there's also actually like Jewish folk
tales and fairy tales in many cases
where magical transformation of this
sort takes place or like even jokes or
something like that which Kafka would
definitely have been familiar with and
he's kind of like coming from that
background so the idea of like an
individual being turned into an animal
or something and then potentially being
turned back or not like there's usually
there's usually a divine presence behind
this right like there's a reason this
has happened but that's what's so kind
of like for us frustrating but also
interesting here is like there is no
reason given right it's just like the
cycle is not resolved because normally
like even in Jewish tradition okay you
have someone like transgressing or
sinning they cross the boundary they get
punished but then there's a way back
after the Exile right like okay there's
a chance for Redemption and here Gregor
just he crawls off and dies there is no
completion to this cycle so that is
interesting but troubling in that sense
because we're definitely invited to at
least think of this in terms of like the
father casting apples and the sun
doesn't have the chance to really like
make up for whatever he's done wrong if
he has even like committed any offense
oh oh wait wait wait they're Catholics
the sun has done nothing wrong the
father kills the Son and the whole
family is redeemed at the end
he's a martyr yeah maybe they get to go
into Paradise which is the beach for
them no and the the ending is really
worth noting again where like the
family's so relieved that Gregor is
finally dead and they take this walk and
as you noted Eric yeah they're they're
they're looking at their daughter and
they notice like wow she's really
growing into a beautiful young woman
it's almost like she's had her own
metamorphosis in that way as as you
noted and she's the one who is now kind
of going to be taking the family forward
so yeah in one way or another Gregor
just needed to get out of the way from
their perspective but it's it's not a
very happy ending for him yeah
okay so if we're done with that I don't
know if it's uh
christiology or just an absurdist dies
for no reason this this one is even more
puzzling though the second thing that
and like you said Victor because
everything's so sparsely described this
really sticks out so in his room there
is a uh
I'll just read it there hung a picture
that he had recently cut out of an
Illustrated magazine and housed a nice
gilded frame
first part it showed a lady fitted with
a fur hat and a fur boa who sat upright
raising a heavy firm muff that covered
the whole lower arm towards the viewer
very
descript she's wearing fur hat fur thing
around her neck I don't know if boa
means anything it's written in German so
I assume not otherwise we'd have a snake
and an apple which should set off all of
our alarms but anyway I don't think
that's probably the case she's got a
thing a further thing around her neck
first thing on her head and a fur thing
on her arm so she's covered with fur
any any thoughts on that and he can't he
can't let it go like he keeps this is
his one object of comfort I guess you
could say this this is his most valued
possession yeah and his sister notably
tries to move this portrait when they're
like you know insect proofing Gregor's
bedroom and he's like he hisses no he he
wants to hang on to this portrait so
yeah this could be seen as like whatever
like it's it's The Last Remnant of his
Humanity or maybe even like his
sexuality because I think with what's
being described here is actually like
it's technically like a a venus and Furs
it's a kind of image of like this woman
who's kind of like scantily glad and
again it's it's not like quite it's not
pornographic but it's erotic and it
actually that there there might be an
intersexual link here to um this the
actual story of Venus infers from 1870
which is which was written by um
I think uh this author in Vienna about
uh this character who goes out after
dark and he has all kinds of interesting
you know sexual encounters and
everything like that and in that story
that the hero notably assumes the name
of Gregor as an alias at one point so
kafka's probably doing a little
intertextual shout out there as well but
even aside from that even aside from
like the implications or the connections
of like you know this interesting almost
like repressed sexuality after dark in a
European city there is this link clearly
like this this image symbolizes an
element of Gregor's Humanity or
sexuality that like he does not want to
lose and his family doesn't understand
this they want to move the portrait
but he he is just really not unhappy
about that
it's also interesting to note that it
was in a gilded frame before he
transformed yeah yeah it it is it does
represent you know his previous
existence before the transformation and
as he's going along right he's he's
listening to what his family is talking
about and mainly like his sister comes
up with this suggestion right oh we
should like take all the furniture out
of his room right and so they're coming
in he says you know they're emptying out
his room taking away everything he was
fond of and in a way he was he was okay
with it because he just discovered to
his Delight that he could you know run
around crawl up the walls and crawl up
the ceilings and his sister was noticing
this as she was cleaning the room and
said hey maybe we should just like make
more room for him and then but then he
hears his mother speaking and his mother
wants to keep everything the way it is
right his mother's saying no we have to
keep the room just the way it is in case
he comes back and he hears this and he's
like oh wait she's right like if they
get rid of all this stuff I'm gonna
completely lose my hand he humanity and
descend into complete bestiality
and so no I need this so he's like tries
to crawl out and puts himself on the
frame and he says he said it says he
crawled up in haste and pressed against
the glass which held him fast and felt
good on his hot belly and he sits there
to try and keep it at least one thing
this one thing in the room they've taken
his dresser out these two frail Little
Women are carrying all this heavy
furniture out he's not concerned about
that he's concerned about now himself
and his he's still holding on to this
little bit of hope that maybe he's going
to retain his sanity and come back to
himself eventually
but
obviously he doesn't right that BOA
thing is like a it's like a a feather
scarf it's like a feathery plush scarf
that you might drape over your shoulders
it's a fashion item and it kind of you
know he gives you some descriptions like
one of the um that big Burly maid she
also wears like an ostrich feather on
her hat he describes that too and
describes it kind of blowing in the wind
that's interesting because they're these
people are already kind of
metamorphosized halfway one's wearing
Furs the other's wearing an ostrich
feather and they're both women
but we're not doing the Freudian reading
no there's definitely something you
could pick up on in terms of Gregor and
his relationship with his sister as well
because like that seems to be like the
most human connection he has also like
his sister's the only one who tries at
least initially to kind of you know
understand Gregor at his new level like
she brings him some food she's trying to
be sympathetic but then as Eric pointed
out like that also leads to the greatest
betrayal because she's the one who says
like you know what I give up on this
thing our Gregor is dead we should move
on and just start over and so I I think
yeah the fact that I think she's the one
trying to move the portrait also like
there might be something going on there
in terms of Gregor his Humanity whatever
and and the sisters calls him out on his
sort of selfish entitlement right
because he's still in this mindset where
I've done so much for this family this
is the least they can do for me and he's
getting angry and he's hissing at them
and and he's he's she calls him out on
it she says you know he wouldn't he
wouldn't be putting us through this if
he was truly thinking about us he was
only thinking about himself and he never
kind of realized that his own sense of
self-realization and gratitude was
actually
predicated on his family depending on
him and becoming enfeebled in that way
and then this is kind of a Poetic
Justice where he's actually the one who
becomes dependent on them and becomes
more and more feeble and bestial to the
point where you know they drive he
drives up completely nuts and father
throws apples at him sister gives up he
crawls out in the room to try and listen
to this violin music and he has this at
one point he just has this complete
deranged fantasy where he's like I'm
gonna bring my sister into my room and
never let her leave and she's going to
play violin for me forever and we're
gonna live happily ever after and you're
just like oh no he's he's lost his mind
now he's completely sunk into this
fantasy of just him being the center of
their world and it calls they call him
out on that right interesting so you
have no patience yeah
the delicate reading of this exact scene
is he wants to re-inscribe the edible
triangle that he lost by becoming a bug
so to reinscribe the edible triangle he
tries to attach himself to this picture
as the mommy side of the triangle her
his sister when she chastises him there
it's actually out of jealousy because he
wants the picture more than he wants her
so that's why she turns on him actually
because he wants the picture more than
he wants her
because he's he's desperate to to
you know he's a military boy he he was
like very faithful to his job he's
trying to reinscribe his place in the
mommy daddy me complex and that's why
his sister who's also competing for that
spot
rejects him
yeah and Eric it sounds like you're
really uh taking the family's viewpoint
on this which is quite interesting
because yeah I mean we you can look at
it from that point of view where like
all his life Gregor has been used to
kind of you know like being the center
of attention that way and now his
sister's kind of overtaking him in that
Dynamic and it leads to this sort of
like Crisis for him but it's it's it's
cool that you mentioned the violin
because that's actually something we
haven't touched on because the yeah his
sister's music especially towards the
end of the story seems to be kind of
like what brings out some of the last
shreds of Gregor's Humanity before he
finally dies and there's actually I
think there's a quote there's a line
where he says uh he specifically kind of
like asks himself
like quote was he an animal that music
could move him so he felt as if the way
to the unknown nourishment he longed for
were coming to light and quote so like
he's he's all he's like the question is
raised of like how much of an animal has
this person become how much should we be
dehumanizing him and how much might
there be a way for Redemption here and
it's it's it's cool that it's actually
his sister's music that might be like
something that could help him here but
it's his sister also who like in the end
like Cuts him off and says nope I'm I'm
done with this like this this creature
so you're lit Vic so I assume you'll be
able to answer this question easily off
the cuff but this music calms The Savage
Beast thing I'm sure that has
hundreds of Illusions in literature is
this referencing any that you can think
of
nothing in particular but what's what's
really cool is that or quite disturbing
in some ways here this question of
dehumanization is like
is almost anticipating something that of
course Kafka would have no way of
knowing but the the dehumanization of
his of Gregor and more specifically of
of course of like certain ethnic groups
later on in the 20th century is
something that becomes quite like
foregrounded here around the music
because his family is just they've
they've given up on thinking of Gregor
as a human right and even in this moment
where his sister is playing music and
Gregor actually comes towards the family
in their living room and he wants to be
part of this moment that's when they
like shoo him away they're like we're
done with you we do not regard you as
one of us and that's when the question
is raised by Gregor himself am I an
animal now
then why am I still being like moved by
this music and for me at least like what
what that points to is like especially
this early in the 20th century is like
the extent to which you know there's a
there's gonna be a lot of sort of
references to dehumanization and stuff
like that further on in literature and
propaganda in Central Europe in the next
decades to the extent where like
questions of humanity and dehumanization
around these things only become more and
more kind of like prevalent that way so
I think that's a really significant
moment in those terms where like the
question of humanity in relation to
culture is just like raised so it's so
fun
well I think so I I had to look it up
but I think the
the main reference is the Leer of
Orpheus because he calms uh he calms
wild animals asleep yeah
oh for sure yeah and that would again be
a call back to the classical
metamorphosis tradition right with Ovid
and things like that so there is
something to be said there again for
like these these older motifs that Kafka
is drawing on to tell a very kind of
like secular fairy tale almost this this
Parable in some ways even though we're
not allegorizing it of course but all
the invitations are there to kind of
think of this in those funny because
these really like brutish and entitled
three dudes that they rent a room out to
come out and they hear like his sister
practicing like she's not even very good
that's that's the thing right they go oh
is that music is that music can we hear
some and the father is of course like
yep yep okay uh Greta come out and play
for for them and they sit there start
listening realize she's not very good so
they start kind of like blowing smoke at
her and getting really impatient and the
door is open to crack so Gregor is
watching all this unfold going these
people don't respect my sister her music
is the best right so but you're reading
the scene and it's just so sad like the
sisters playing this music these people
hate it but they're just out of sheer
courtesy they're not saying anything
and they're having this this really
again this sort of perverse performance
where nobody's liking it and then Gregor
just kind of goes into this immediate
fantasy like I'm gonna steal her away
and keep her in my room with me
and it's it's odd well
does he go that far does he just want to
like fund her music at the conservatory
because I think he's sort of like he's
yearning to be the breadwinner again
right that that's kind of what the music
also brings out in him he's like
I can help her but I need to like
reconnect more with this music but then
I thought here he's like you know he's
right after that quote you mentioned he
says despite his transformed State he
said he was resolved to push his way
right up to his sister and tug at his
skirt as an indication to come into his
room with her violin he intended never
to let her out of his room again at
least not as long as he lived his
horrifying shape was to be beneficial to
him for the first time he would be on
guard at the doors of his room at once
and spit at his assailants like a cat
but his sister would remain with him not
under compulsion but voluntarily she was
to sit next to him on this couch and
incline her ear towards him like he goes
on and on in this just this fever dream
right near the end
the dream in which he's violating the
taboo of incest
you could take it there for sure but
then it's punctured because then the
actually the the the rumors the rentiers
they the renters notice him go Mr Sansa
and they point at him and then the music
stops and his sister kind of just goes
into this trance she's like so
depressed I guess uh by this whole
experience and they then the then the
room renters threaten to leave because
they're like this disgusting you know
beast that's been right next to us this
whole time and the family's been keeping
this dirty little secret this whole time
because they know he's been in there yet
they've been trying to like squeeze a
few extra bucks out of the apartment by
renting some of the space yeah the how
the house value instantly plummets once
they realize there's like a man-sized
cockroach living in there but yeah
Vermin bug maybe yeah so that that that
uh passage you read Eric that that does
kind of like evoke a Beauty and the
Beast scenario where like you know he's
the sister would be trapped with Gregor
and she would slowly heal him with her
music yeah it's maybe maybe there is an
ancestral taboo here which which has
also been crossed but uh lots to think
about yeah
well look I'm just I'm throwing things
out but though I guess the in the end
you can't read this as a christianology
you can't read it as just a Freudian uh
taboo
every because every time you you like
commit to one reading you can't read it
as like oh the guy's depressed anytime
you commit to one reading there's just
very distinct plot elements that kind of
pull that meaning apart and you know
like the capitalist reading you might
want to go for it too right yeah the
alienation the bureaucracy it starts
with that but it's never brought up
again really
um his death heals his family in a weird
way that
like what does that mean what did he do
wrong we don't know so it resists uh
being read a certain way but there is so
much like literary references in here
throughout that
I don't know that's probably intentional
I'm not good enough with literature to
know you know but it's it's what makes
it so rewarding too because like it
doesn't sort of like tie itself up we
have to actively kind of like work as
readers to sort of figure out how this
is Meaningful or like useful for us
right and I think like all these
elements are there like we're not
reaching too far when we talk about you
know the biblical or kind of like Jewish
traditions in here or of course like the
capitalist sort of socialist
implications of Gregor's status here
ultimately though like what what seems
to come across is that the sadness of
the family's abandonment of their son
and brother like that that is something
that like is kind of inescapable at the
plot level like there's something kind
of like
it's deeply upsetting about the way that
like they the more Gregor becomes
comfortable in his new form the less the
family kind of like recognizes him as
their relative
and perhaps like that that's sort of
like the final commentary on like even
the question of interpretation here is
like whatever else we might think of
this story like clearly the family has
failed to interpret Gregor properly like
whatever they've done like they are they
have mistread the situation they don't
know what to do with him they think he's
a burden and Gregor again is not like
disgusted by his form he just he needs
some sympathy and understanding and they
do not provide that for him so
whatever we are supposed to do with this
story like clearly the family kind of is
a warning of what maybe we shouldn't be
doing so that's
yeah and the one thing that we did not
bring up that I would like to bring up
that was my favorite part it's not the
plot elements and it's not the symbolism
but just the even in Translation like I
would love to be able to read German to
get the sense of it but these punctuated
sentences with vivid descriptions like I
said I find the absurdity of some of the
descriptions kind of funny but it's
short sentences feels a little bit
claustrophobic
there's very a a I want to describe it
as a compressed sense of time
like an urgency that's felt throughout
that never is actually you don't know
what you're being urgent about but it
feels
compressed claustrophobic anyway I'm
describing my affective sense of the
story
because uh I that's really the thing
that kept me going was like I can I how
fast can I read this but then eventually
sitting there and reading it this I I
fell into the pace of it which I really
appreciated a lot you can't get that if
we are doing your homework for you with
this episode you can't get that from
hearing a summary you gotta that's
really got that sort of James joycey
kind of element of of uh of um a moment
in time being really really dragged out
across many many pages and it does Jump
Around in time but the the barrage of
details and the kind of painful
uh extensions of of what's happening
just through sheer description is is uh
is definitely you know this is the time
of modernist literature right they're
experimenting with form they're trying
to push the envelope of what you can do
with the short story form which which is
not that I as far as I know it's not
that old at this point the short story
form the 19th century maybe this is when
short stories really became you know
solidified as a as a uh as a respectable
kind of literary vehicle and now
in this early 20th century you have you
know Ezra pound make it new and and
Kafka is certainly doing something here
with that
well most of the [ __ ] that I read these
days is like you you read the novel that
is just meant to be turned into a movie
like Game of Thrones is the best example
the the internal thoughts are like not
all that interesting it's heavily plot
based I was thinking this whole time
this could only be
probably a short story it couldn't it
couldn't even be longer than this and
you couldn't adapt it to a visual
presentation because so much of it is
dependent on his observations of of
things around him his own thoughts his
family's thoughts his family's actions
like it would be the it would be a
terrible film and it could only be in
this form which is I I was it was
refreshing because I don't really read
literature as much as I would like no
but that's a great point and yeah this
is not a homework read at all like it's
a really fun story even in like the tone
as as you were noting pills it's so
understated in comparison with what's
actually happening like there it's so
minimal in the way that it just
describes this stuff almost a matter of
factly but just uh two quick things to
note as well is that yeah Kafka didn't
even want like an image on the cover of
like whatever creature Gregor has
transformed into he deliberately I think
wants that ambiguity there for like you
know you fill in the blank as a reader
what we're dealing with here so yeah I
think that this works especially well as
a text and it would be it would be
tricky to adapt this for the screen for
sure but the other thing we haven't
touched on is actually like the um the
perspective that the story is being told
from right because we've been talking
about it and it's not actually from
Gregor's point of view which is
interesting it's it's kind of third
person but like third person limited so
we kind of we follow him around and we
see a little bit more than him but not
much more like we're kind of with Gregor
the whole time except for after his
death at the very end so
I think that that's pretty deliberate
because like we we obviously identify a
little bit more strongly with him
because of that but it's also nice
because like I think if it were first
person it would lose something it would
it would be too easy to just dismiss
this and say okay this is just a guy
going crazy or having a bad dream right
but because we are outside of Gregor
it's like again it gets back to that
like literal nature of the story like no
this is really happening like this is
not a dream this is not a metaphor this
is real in a way that like we can see a
little bit more objectively from the
from our perspective as the fact that we
get about 10 more paragraphs after the
death of Gregor is is indicative of the
The Narrative perspective completely
just at that point breaks away you think
it's all from Gregor's perspective but
it's not because the narration continues
but the perspective is dead and then it
just kind of describes the that's after
that that's the day new mod it's it's
done they're describing the end of it or
the the the maid comes in pokes them
with a stick
and go and then calls and and she's
really irreverent she's like oh it's
croaked it's it's it kicked the bucket
you know and the family's like what what
are you talking about like oh he's dead
oh and then and then there's just this
lift there's just this this relief this
burden is completely removed and you get
eight or ten more paragraphs of just
like how the family then just emerges
from the shell of this horrible
nightmare and go becomes I don't know
normal again as normal as post covet's
gonna be
can I just read it it's like it's almost
it's almost sardonic how happy they are
they emerge into the sunshine which has
to be they're asked let's get let's
finish with this analysis so most of the
last paragraph I'll just read here after
that the three of them
the family uh minus Gregor left the flat
together which was something they had
not done for months and took the tram
out to the Open Country outside of town
they had the tram filled with warm
sunshine all to themselves leaned back
comfortably on their seats they
discussed the prospects and found that
on closer examination they were not at
all bad until then they had never asked
each other about their work but all
three had jobs which were very good and
held quite a particularly good promise
for the future the greatest Improvement
for the time being of course would be
achieved quite easily by moving house
what they needed now was a flat that was
smaller and cheaper than the current one
that had been chosen by Gregor one that
was in a better location and most of all
more practical all the time Greta was
becoming livelier and etc etc etc it's
almost the nightmares
[Music]
yeah and they actually specifically End
by like noting just how good looking a
young woman Greta is becoming and like
she stretches her arms out and that's
the final line it's it's kind of like
again going back to this idea of there
being like a metamorphosis for her as
well that she's become of eligible
marrying age it's they've completely
shifted their focus from Gregor to the
daughter now
so yeah the tone is like really at odds
with the tragedy alleged tragedy you
know that hasn't sued there's no lament
for Gregor there's no real sense of like
a loss in the family and
yeah I mean it it goes back again to
this idea of like
how are we supposed to sort of process
this whole story it's like whatever
we're doing we kind of know like the
families the family has not done a good
job of dealing with this difficult truth
they've they've repressed or dismissed
something
in a way that like they probably
shouldn't have and the awkwardness of
Gregor's existence like it we we're not
necessarily meant to come up with a
final interpretation of that because
again as we've seen that's a Fool's
Aaron but we shouldn't completely
dismiss what happened either in the way
that the families Greta's sort of
emergence blossoming is deeply
contrasted this is just kafka's like
genius for creating these like Whiplash
contrasts is just like indeed Gregor's
body was completely flat and dry
actually that could be seen only now
when he was no longer lifted up on his
little legs and nothing else diverted
their attention so he's just been fading
away and they really didn't notice it
but that comes out at the end and just
makes this huge point of contrast with
then Greta's sort of then they then they
notice her and she she's she's bloomed
right I know we're at time I want to
stay on this point for a second because
this just brought back the memory of
another one of his texts um the Hunger
Artist
so the basic plot I'm sorry again
spoiler if you guys haven't read it but
the plot of the the Hunger Artist is
there's a guy who starves himself for
other people's entertainment in like on
a stage in the middle of town or in a
cage I think actually it is he starves
himself and people come by and they
observe him starving himself eventually
he Withers away and dies and no one
cares because everyone has lost interest
in the art of starving yourself and
immediately at the end of the at the end
of the story final paragraph they
replace him with a tiger and everybody
is so interested in the tiger they all
come watch the tiger it's full of life
Lively and that replacement is happening
right here as well and as I've said
several times throughout this I'm not
good at the at the interpretive but I
wanted to know like if it happens twice
it's definitely intentional one person
Withers away painfully excruciatingly
slowly and then something full of life
sexual sensual energetic takes it yeah
that definitely lines up with you know
the descriptions of the darkness in the
room that Gregor is hiding in and the
lights that the family emerges into at
the end like if you want like a visual
metaphor for that that's kairoscuro
right heavy light and heavy Shadow all
in the same frame and that's what he's
doing there he's he's doing this kind of
kairoscuro black and like it's described
as a story in black and white I think
that's Nabokov uses that and it really
you get that but then you can go further
with that with verbal literature right
because you can then
then hang on all these other things as
well all these other contrasts can come
forth yeah and in in some way again like
the the contrast between Gregor's
transformation and his sisters at the
end is it it does sort of like draw
attention to itself and especially in
the way that the family seems to have
somehow stifled the sun's transformation
but they're they're really happy about
the daughter's changes and again going
back to the father like pelting apples
at the Sun and it's those apples which
ultimately like lead to the wound that
kills Gregor it's a lot of this comes
down to the way that the family reacted
to this unusual situation and the extent
to which they weren't able to kind of
you know properly interpret their their
son's uh changes yeah
it's also I mean this is like my best
attempt at interpretation but
in this story and the other story that I
was referencing
this the person that's hanging around is
kind of they're they're suffering is a
little bit self-inflicted and kind of
absurd like it's not really anybody's
fault
um but they they continue until they die
then it's a relief to everybody and then
we can you know move on with our lives
and kind of replace it which I guess
points to a bit of just sufferings
absurd you you try to put meaning on it
but ultimately it matters to you no one
else is expected to care and they're
probably annoyed that you have to go
through this anyway
yeah and it also kind of speaks to the
commercial or transactional nature of a
lot of these relationships right and
even maybe like the transactional nature
or the sort of the fleeting nature of
the story in itself like the act of
Storytelling is over the novelty is gone
all right we're just going to dispose of
this now and move on to the next shiny
thing but should we be doing that I mean
there there's different ways in which
this sort of theme of like you know
replacing what is withered with
something new and fresh is kind of uh
clearly being played with here by Kafka
yeah so they you said at the beginning
they don't have Happy Endings but
technically they do it's just slammed
into like four lines at the very end
well you know if you're like Eric and
you're with Team uh patriarchal father
then of course it's a it's a it's a
happy ending but Gregor isn't doing so
well no just one one last little note on
the I on on the German term actually for
Gregor's uh insect hood here because I
think this might help us sort of put a
bow on some of us at least uh so we
talked about how he's called a monstrous
like insect or Vermin in English but
apparently in German the term is it's an
older term that Kafka uses I'm gonna try
to pronounce it it's uh
zifer which has implications of of
something which is no longer suitable
for sacrifice
so like something old and disgusting and
like no longer like acceptable in a
certain way is that no longer part of
the word because
like a fallen a fallen thing
yeah maybe Eric would do a better job on
the German than me but the the older
implications of that term at least in an
archaic sense seem to be something which
has no longer like acceptable
as a sacrificial offering as well yeah
that's I mean the the term itself yeah
that's that's better than I could do
with the meaning of it yeah it kind of
just means yeah and it means bug Vermin
but then it has all those those older
implications yeah filthy and un unclean
in a way that in Jewish Traditions
especially refers to like you know like
ritual cleansing and sacrifice as well
yeah could you call it like a pest in
English because we refer to pests as
yeah my translation's enormous bug
unwanted
it could be insect could be rodent could
be weird it wouldn't it wouldn't capture
all those sort of meaning you're missing
in the German there's again as as Eric
brought up like the sense of the
grotesque and the disgusting is really
important here there's just there's like
a primal reaction to like wanting to get
rid of this thing whatever it is at
least for the family and then as readers
we're kind of like you know we are left
to decide how much we agree with them
yeah it's Fallen it's unclean the
nightmare is over but there's a odd
taste in your mouth at the end
no matter how happy that ending is
that's not gonna that's not gonna erase
well if if this was a movie adaptation
you can just see like Greta's has a baby
or something and like all of a sudden
the baby's legs start twitching and like
and the transformation begins again
Yeah question mark yeah well listener
and you guys uh the nightmare of this
podcast is over and we can
it's it's pretty sunny here Blue Sky we
can it's a beautiful fall day it's a
little late but it's [ __ ] cold anyway
we don't need to go into that uh thank
you so much again Victor lit Vic for
showing up do you wanna do you wanna
shout out to anything do you want people
to follow you on anything yeah so I'm on
Twitter as well uh you can probably put
the link in the video description but
yeah other than that
um definitely check out this story even
if we've kind of unpacked it for you a
little bit because again it's not a
homework read it's a lot of fun and
there's really regardless of all that
we've kind of like talk about there's no
final say on it like the whole point is
that everyone's gonna get something like
interesting and unique out of this kind
of a story so it's a trip either way and
people are people are still reading it
like it's got uh for a good reason yeah
it it does speak to something that is
clearly still relative
I'm sure it's this it's sure it's read
in in queer Theory disability studies
all that kind of thing anyway
uh thank you listeners this has been uh
something like 94 I hope that's right 94
feels like a a little bit of a Kafka ask
number it's not quite anywhere but it's
almost almost somewhere triple digits
here we come
so with that said you've escaped the
Maze and uh you can Ascend into the warm
light of day as long as you have a
brother to sex I'm gonna go have an
apple made me hungry
all right goodbye
ciao bye
[Music]